hi everyone
this is professor m science and today i
want to introduce the harmonic
oscillator
in another one of her videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics if you have studied
classical physics you will know that the
harmonic oscillator is one of the most
important systems in the whole of
physics
the harmonic oscillator allows us to
study problems ranging from the
vibration of strings all the way to the
behavior of electronic circuits
you won't be surprised to hear that the
harmonic oscillator plays a similarly
central role in quantum mechanics in the
quantum world it allows us to study
properties ranging
from the motion of atoms in solids to
the behavior of light but there is
another very important reason
why the quantum harmonic oscillator is
key it is one of only a handful of
problems that we know how to solve
exactly so it is very commonly used to
exemplify
really important concepts in quantum
mechanics and as you can imagine this is
something that is extremely valuable
when you're starting to learn quantum
theory
so let's go the harmonic oscillator is a
key system
both in classical and quantum mechanics
and its defining feature is that it is a
system
with a potential energy that depends
quadratically on the amplitude
let's draw a pair of axes we place the
x coordinate on the horizontal axis
and the potential energy v of x on the
vertical axis
the potential energy of a
one-dimensional harmonic oscillator is
then proportional to
x squared and we conventionally define
the proportionality constant
as one-half times k where k is a
positive constant
we can now draw this harmonic potential
right here
in classical mechanics we know that the
force experienced by a particle
is given by the negative of the gradient
of the potential
in which it moves in the case of the
harmonic potential we get this
derivative
which is equal to minus kx
from this we can very clearly see how a
classical particle moves in a harmonic
potential
if x is larger than zero in this region
then the force is
negative so it pushes the particle
towards the origin
if x is smaller than zero then the force
is
positive again pushing the particle
towards the origin
overall we get a particle oscillating
back and forth
about the origin i will not solve the
classical problem here but
my guess is that most of you will have
encountered it before
if you haven't you can check pretty much
any book on classical mechanics
to find the solution from the solution
of the classical harmonic oscillator
we know that the motion of a particle of
mass m is a harmonic motion of frequency
omega where omega is equal to the square
root of k over n
with this omega we can rewrite the
potential up here
like this which is a very commonly used
form
perhaps the most famous classical system
undergoing harmonic motion
is that of a mass attached to a string
and in that context this expression here
for the force is called
hooke's law however there are actually
many different situations which can be
described
using harmonic potentials and what i
want to do next is to discuss
why that is the case
let's start by drawing our pair of axes
again
we now consider a general arbitrary
potential which i'm just making up as i
am drawing it
this particular potential has three
local minima one here which we label
x zero one here which we label x one
and one here which we label x two
let's now zoom in into the region of the
potential
near x zero and redraw this region
we know that classically if a particle
is placed at a local minimum here it
will stay there in a state of static
equilibrium
because the force vanishes at the
minimum
if we now displace the particle away
from the minimum but insist
that this displacement is small we can
approximate
the general potential v about the
minimum x0
using a taylor expansion it is given by
the value of the potential at the
minimum
then we have the first order term the
second order term
the third order term
and so on as we're expanding about the
minimum
at x zero then by definition of a
minimum
this first order derivative vanishes so
the linear term
is zero for small enough displacement
then the dominant term in the expansion
will be the lowest order term which
is the quadratic term here what we can
therefore do to describe the motion per
particle near the minimum
is to discard all higher order terms and
only retain
the quadratic term this is of course an
approximation and we should always check
its validity graphically we can add a
quadratic to our general potential and
we see that it agrees
with the real potential near the minimum
but it deviates when we're sufficiently
far away
allowing us to quantify when the
harmonic approximation is valid
in practice there is a very large number
of physical systems which can be
described
accurately while only keeping the
quadratic term
and this is why what we're doing here is
so important
whatever arbitrary potential we have and
however complex it is
if our particle is close enough to a
local minimum
then its motion can be approximated by a
simple potential just like this one
that depends quadratically on the
displacement from the minimum
this particular potential is slightly
different to the canonical harmonic
potential that we were discussing
earlier
because there is this constant term here
and this position
offset here this is really just a detail
we can shift the origin of both axes to
turn this expression into the canonical
form
by adding a constant minus v x0 we get
rid of the constant term
and by shifting the origin of the x-axis
to x0
we also remove the offset
right so the final step is to identify
this object here which is a constant
because it is a derivative evaluated at
the origin
with the constant k we had earlier
we've just seen how harmonic potentials
can be used to approximate the motion of
a particle
near an arbitrary minimum of a general
one-dimensional potential
the same is true for higher dimensional
potentials
now imagine that we have a potential
that depends on n
variables then we can always expand
that potential about a minimum and the
lowest order
term will be the quadratic term here i'm
already assuming
that i have a coordinate system in which
the energy at the minimum
is zero and the minimum is located at
the origin
but if this wasn't the case we can
always make a simple transformation
to make it so again close enough to the
minimum we can discard
all higher order terms and we're left
with a quadratic term
only this quadratic term looks somewhat
more complicated
than the one for a one-dimensional
system because there are cross terms
which involve the derivatives with
respect to
two different coordinates here and here
however it turns out that for
hamiltonians with quadratic potentials
it is always possible to make a change
of coordinates from the original
x to a new set u and in this new set of
coordinates the potential
becomes decoupled like this
as a result the total hamiltonian can be
described as
n individual one-dimensional harmonic
oscillators
therefore if we work in terms of u
coordinates the problem reduces again
to the simple 1d problem that we had
earlier with the small caveat that we
have to solve a total of
n 1d problems rather than just one
these new coordinates u are a concept
that appears in many branches of physics
and are called normal modes
using this approach many interesting
systems can be described by simply
knowing how to solve the one-dimensional
harmonic oscillator a prominent example
of this is the description of how atoms
vibrate
in solids in the quantum theory this is
encoded by
phonons which contain information about
a plethora of quantities such as the
speed of sound
or the heat capacity and contribute to
multiple phenomena
such as heat transport or
superconductivity
another well-known example of the
application of harmonic oscillators is
in the description of the
electromagnetic field
as we'll see quantizing the harmonic
oscillator
is relatively straightforward so
describing systems such as these in
terms of harmonic oscillators
provides a really powerful platform on
which to study them
using quantum mechanics
now that i have hopefully convinced you
of the relevance of the harmonic
oscillator
all we have left to do is to discuss it
in the context of quantum mechanics
the total energy of harmonic oscillator
is given by
the sum of the kinetic energy and the
potential energy that we've been
discussing
to move to quantum mechanics all we have
to do
is to promote the position and momentum
to the corresponding operators this
means that we can write down the
hamiltonian of a quantum harmonic
oscillator
like this
what we'll do in this series of videos
on the quantum harmonic oscillator
is to study the properties of this
hamiltonian
i really cannot emphasize enough the
importance of the quantum harmonic
oscillator
it is one of only a handful of quantum
systems that can be solved exactly
this makes it a really useful system to
exemplify
all the key concepts when learning about
quantum mechanics
but the fact that it is one of the few
potentials that we know how to solve
analytically also means that it is used
to explain the physics of a lot of very
important systems in other words
everything that we learn from this
hamiltonian will be immediately useful
to understand phenomena as diverse as
atomic vibrations in solids
or light the quantum harmonic oscillator
is a problem that you will encounter
time and again in your study of physics
we have many other videos that look into
different aspects of the quantum
harmonic oscillator so i wanted to
encourage you to check them out because
it will give you a really comprehensive
overview of what this type of problem is
all about and as always
if you liked the video please subscribe